Ausnahmsweise lagen die Prognostiker mal richtig.
Der französische Präsident Enmanuel Macron
hat die zweite Runde der französischen Präsidentschaftswahlen
nicht nur gewonnen, sondern auch seine Konkurrentin
Marine Le Pen mit einem Abstand von 16 Prozentpunkten
ausgestochen: etwa 58% für Macron, 42% für
Le Pen.
Ein Vorsprung, der sich gegenüber den letzten
Präsidentschaftswahlen zwar halbiert hat
– damals betrug er satte 32 Punkte - aber
wir sprechen immer noch von einem großen
Unterschied für ein Land, in dem Wiederwahlen
nicht gerade üblich sind.
Es ist erste Mal seit 20 Jahren, dass ein
französischer Präsident seine zweite Amtszeit
antreten wird.
Und es ist gar das erste Mal seit mehr als
50 Jahren, dass ein Präsident das politische
Leben vollständig dominiert, ohne mit einer
Regierung und einem Premierminister aus einer
anderen, von der Nationalversammlung gewählten
Partei, zusammenarbeiten zu müssen.
Dies ist noch beachtenswerter, wenn man bedenkt,
dass die Wiederwahl nach Corona-Krise und
inmitten einer riesigen Inflationsspirale
stattfand.
Überdies war die die Zahl der Nichtwähler
enorm hoch.
Und was soll ich sagen: wenn man etwas am
Status Quo ändern möchte, bleibt man ja
am Wahltag normalerweise nicht zu Hause.
Le Pen wäre den meisten daheim Gebliebenen
dann doch wohl zu viel der Veränderung gewesen.
Mit anderen Worten: So sehr Macron für die
niedrige Wahlbeteiligung und das Zusammenschmelzen
des Abstands zu Le Pen kritisiert wurde: unterm
Strich können wir fast von einem neuen Sonnenkönig
der französischen Politik sprechen.
Er ist nicht der beliebteste Führer und hat
den Ruf, autoritär zu sein, aber er hat die
Führung im Amt und im Land.
Und ja, das Merkwürdiste daran ist eben,
dass die Franzosen ihn gar nicht so gut leiden
können.
In Meinungsumfragen wird ihm regelmäßig
vorgeworfen, arrogant, autoritär und abgehoben
zu sein.
Naja, manche sagen sich wohl: Einbildung ist
auch 'ne Bildung.
Aber ich bin sicher, dass Fotos wie dieses
nicht gerade hilfreich sind:
Und nicht nur das.
Wir können nicht einmal sagen, dass er in
der Lage wäre, mit seinen politischen Vorschlägen
die Massen mitzunehmen.
In der ersten Runde unterstützten fast 60
% der französischen Wähler die Kandidaten
der extremen Rechten oder der extremen Linken.
Und die Nichtwählerquote von 28 Prozentpunkten
in der zweiten Wahlrunde ist ebenfalls die
höchste in einem halben Jahrhundert.
Es ist klar, dass Macron keine Leidenschaften
weckt.
Aber warum hat der Mann, der seine Lehrerin
und Mutter seiner Schulfreundin ehelichte,
so einen Erfolg?
Warum hatte die Frau, die ihren Vater politisch
ermordet hat, keine Chance gegen ihn?
Wohin steuert die französische Politik und
was können wir in seiner neuen Amtszeit in
Frankreich erwarten?
Sind die Franzosen psycho-politisch in einer
ödipal-freudianischen Dichotomie gefangen?
Falls Ihr keine Ahnung habt, was ich da von
mir gebe, es aber trotzdem interessant klingt,
dann spitzt jetzt Eure Lauscher.
Wir machen uns auf in ein Land, in dem die
politischen Uhren ganz schön "fou" ticken.
(WARUM MACRON?)
Der französische Staatschef hat Frankreich
mit harter Hand geführt.
Als er 2017 an die Macht kam, war er weder
rechts noch links, sondern versuchte, ein
neues Frankreich zu gestalten.
Während seiner ersten Amtszeit gab es Zeiten,
in denen seine Präsidentschaft kurz vor dem
Ende zu stehen schien, doch er kam immer wieder
auf die Beine.
Wieder und wieder.
Da waren zum Beispiel die Aufstände der Gelbwesten,
die größten Proteste seit Jahrzehnten, oder
auch die Corona-Krise, bei der die Franzosen
anfangs zu den größten Impfgegnern gehörten.
Heute sind 78% der Bevölkerung durchgeimpft,
ein höherer Prozentsatz als in Deutschland,
dem Vereinigten Königreich oder den USA.
Vor allem hat er aber versucht, Frankreich
zu modernisieren.
Und wenn wir über die Modernisierung des
gallischen Landes sprechen, geht es vor allem
um seine Wirtschaft.
Um Euch eine Vorstellung zu geben: Frankreichs
Wirtschaft ist in den letzten 10 Jahren im
Schnitt um 1% gewachsen.
Und wenn wir statt der Wirtschaft als Ganzes
das BIP pro Kopf betrachten...
nun, ich denke, ein Bild sagt mehr als tausend
Worte.
In US-Dollar ausgedrückt, haben die Franzosen
seit mehr als 14 Jahren an Wohlstand verloren,
aber selbst wenn wir die Auswirkungen von
Wechselkursen und Preisschwankungen eliminieren,
ist das Ergebnis nicht viel besser.
Im gesamten Jahrzehnt vor Corona stieg die
Wirtschaftsleistung Frankreichs um kaum 6%.
Das ist eine viel schlechtere Bilanz als die
der meisten Industrieländer.
Mit anderen Worten: Wie du siehst, liegt die
französische Wirtschaft praktisch im Wochkoma.
Wenn wir die Zahlen des letzten Jahrzehnts
beschreiben würden, könnten wir, selbst
wenn wir großzügig wären, sagen, dass sie
mehr als enttäuschend sind.
Wir sprechen von einem Defizit von mehr als
6% des BIP, einer Staatsverschuldung von mehr
als 112%, exorbitanten öffentlichen Ausgaben
von nicht weniger als 55% des BIP und praktisch
keinem Wachstum während der letzten Jahre.
Selbst unter den größten Kraftanstrengungen
und bei bestem Willen ist es extrem schwierig,
iregndeine Statistik zu finden, in der die
Dinge für die Grande Nation wirklich gut
laufen.
Ein guter Indikator könnte die Industrieproduktion
sein, da sie sich in den Industrieländern
auf einem Allzeithoch befindet und Frankreich
ja traditionell ein stark industialisiertes
Land ist.
Die Frage ist also: Wie hat sich die Industrieproduktion
in Frankreich entwickelt?
Nun, auch hier gilt: Ein Bild sagt mehr als
tausend Worte.
Um dieses Problem anzugehen, hat Macron Anstrengungen
unternommen, die Wirtschaft zu deregulieren
und die Steuern zu senken.
Bemühungen, die von der Wirtschaft sehr gut
aufgenommen wurden und es zum Beispiel ermöglicht
haben, dass die Arbeitslosigkeit auf 7 % gesunken
ist, den niedrigsten Stand seit 2008.
Zu seinen Erfolgen gehört auch die Tatsache,
dass sich Frankreich von den großen europäischen
Volkswirtschaften am schnellsten von der Krise
erholt.
Wie du in dieser Grafik sehen kannst, war
Frankreich die einzige große Volkswirtschaft,
die sich bis Ende 2021 auf das Niveau vor
den Lockdowns erholt hat.
Eine seiner ersten Maßnahmen nach seiner
Vereidigung als Präsident im Jahr 2017 war
die Abschaffung der Vermögenssteuer.
Und unter seinen großen Erfolgen werden in
der Regel die Senkung der Körperschaftssteuer,
also Unternehmenssteuern, um 8 Punkte und
die Arbeitsmarktreform hervorgehoben, die
das Einstellen und Entlassen von Mitarbeitern
erleichtert.
Vielleicht ist es deshalb nicht überraschend,
dass laut Umfragen fast 8 von 10 Führungskräften
aus der Wirtschaft für den französischen
Präsidenten gestimmt haben.
Aber auf jeden Fall reden wir über nur kleine
Veränderungen.
Zumindest viel kleiner als das, was die französische
Wirtschaft wirklich bräuchte.
Aber natürlich sind sie besser als gar nicht
und für eine Übergangszeit haben sie funktioniert.
Und genau diese Linie hat Macron auch jetzt
wieder eingeschlagen.
Er hat unter anderem versprochen, die Produktionssteuern
für Unternehmen und Selbstständige um 7
Milliarden Euro zu senken, die Erbschaftssteuer
zu reduzieren und bis 2027 ein Defizit von
3 % des BIP zu erreichen.
Mit anderen Worten: diskrete Anpassungen und
fünf weitere Jahre wilder Ausgabenorgien.
Denn man hat's ja... eben nicht!
Allein seit Beginn des Krieges in der Ukraine
hat die französische Regierung 22 Milliarden
Euro ausgegeben, um Verbraucher und Unternehmen
für die Preiserhöhungen bei Gas, Strom und
Benzin zu entschädigen.
Das alles kommt aus den öffentlichen Kassen.
Schätzungen zufolge werden Macrons Wohltaten
das französische Staatsdefizit um 44 Milliarden
Euro pro Jahr erhöhen, anstatt sein Wuchern
endlich zu stoppen.
Und das auch nur, wenn er seine Versprechen
einhält und es nicht noch doller kommt.
Zu erwarten ist es nicht.
Denn wenn Macron während seiner ersten Amtszeit
etwas gelernt hat war es, dass man außepolitisch
nur forsch und ausdauern genug auftreten muss,
bis Berlin einknickt und seine Rechnungen
bezahlt, ob in Form von Euro- bzw. Corona-Bonds
oder wie auch immer.
Daher ist es schon mehr als klar, dass er
eine noch aggressivere internationale Rolle
anstrebt als bisher.
Macron will, dass Paris in Brüssel das Sagen
hat.
In den letzten Monaten haben wir zum Beispiel
gesehen, wie er in der Ukraine-Krise eine
sehr wichtige Rolle spielen wollte.
Auch wenn das nicht besonders gut geklappt
hat.
Der gute alte Schuljunge Emmanuel dachte doch
allen Ernstes, er könne Wladimir Putin durch
stundenlange Telefonate zur Vernunft zu bringen.
Wahrscheinlich blickte er während der für
ihn nervenaufreibenden Telefonate ständig
in die Augen seiner Frau, während ihn der
Kremlherrscher genüsslich trollte und so
wertvolle Zeit schinden konnte.
Marcon wollte dadurch nicht nur vor der Wahl
noch Punkte sammeln, sein Profil als der modeäne
und professionelle Staatsmann schärfen, als
der er immer gerne auftritt.
Doch wie gesagt: das alles sind nur Auftritte,
denn alles was übrig blieb, war das Bild
eines amateurhaften Naivlings.
Gut gemeint ist eben nur sehr selten "gut
gemacht", oft das genaue Gegenteil.
Vor allem, wenn dabei das "gewusst wie" vollkommen
fehlt und man mit dem guten Zweck eigentlich
noch einen bösen verbinden will.
Denn in Wahrheit ging es Macron bei seinen
Putin-Telefonaten noch um etwas eher niederträchtiges:
Rache.
Wohlgemerkt: nicht an Putin, sondern an seinen
eigenen Verbündeten.
Ich werde Euch gleich verraten, was ich damit
meine.
Schließlich ging nämlich auch dieses Vorhaben
Macrons total in dies Hose, weswegen die französische
Regierung Europa bei der Einführung eines
Ölembargos gegen Russland natürlich unterstützen
wird.
Die Ukraine-Krise hat uns also wieder einmal
den unbeständigen, wankelmütigen und auch
verachtungsvollen Charakter Macrons vor Augen
geführt.
Es handelt sich vielleicht um die schlimmste
Seite des französischen Präsidenten: den
ewigen pariser Opportunismus.
(DER OPPORTUNISTISCHSTE ASPEKT DES FRANZÖSISCHEN
PRÄSIDENTEN)
Macron wollte die Spannungen an der ukrainischen
Grenze nutzen, um sich von Washington zu distanzieren,
eine eigene europäische Position zu beanspruchen,
mit Putin zu verhandeln und sich damit für
den Affront zu rächen, den er mit AUKUS erlitten
hat.
Damals handelte es sich bereits um eine schwärzesten
Augenblicke der französischen Außen- und
Bündnispolitik.
Paris bekam die Quittung für sein opportunistisches
Lavieren, als die australische Regierung einen
millionenschweren U-Boot-Deal mit der französischen
Militärindustrie stornierte, um einen besseren
mit den Vereinigten Staaten und dem Vereinigten
Königreich abzuschließen.
Und das war nicht das Schlimmste.
Das Schlimmste war, dass Paris davon im Grunde
erst aus der Presse erfahren hat.
Ein weiterer Beweis dafür, wie wenig vom
Einfluss der Grande Nation übrig gebliegen
ist.
Mit der jetzigen Politik ist es auf dem besten
Wege, zusammen mit Deutschland im Orkus der
Geopolitik zu verschwinden.
Ihr wisst, dass wir hier bei VisualPolitik
Verfechtes des europäischen Gedankens und
Einheit sind, aber im Angesicht dessen, was
diese beiden Länder vorführen, wirkt der
Brexit immer mehr wie ein "FreDxit": der Exit
Frankreichs und Deutschlands aus dem Kreis
der Weltmächte, die noch was zu melden haben.
Sie verlieren immer mehr den Anschluss.
Das eine, weil es führen will, es aber nicht
kann und das andere, weil es irgendwie auch
führen will, aber nicht die Eier hat, es
zuzugeben.
Und es außerdem auch nicht kann.
Gut, im Gegensatz zum deutschen Kanzler - denn
noch mehr Opportunismus und Wankelmut geht
immer - spricht es der französische Präsident
wenigstens offen aus:
(Die Europäer müssen aufhören, naiv zu
sein [...] Wir müssen reagieren und zeigen,
dass wir die Kraft und die Fähigkeit haben,
uns zu verteidigen" Emmanuel Macron)
Und ausgerechnet als es in der Ukraine heiß
herging, dachte Macron, dies sei die perfekte
Gelegenheit, der US-Regierung einen Tritt
in den Hintern zu verpassen.
Deshalb hat er im Europaparlament selbst die
folgende Erklärung abgegeben:
("Es ist gut, wenn sich die Europäer und
die Vereinigten Staaten abstimmen, aber die
Europäer müssen ihren eigenen Dialog führen."
- Emmanuel Macron, vor dem Europäischen Parlament)
Kein gemeinsamer Standpunkt, keine Verstärkung
der NATO oder ähnliches.
Die Europäische Union musste im Alleingang
mit Putin verhandeln.
Und als typischer Sonnenkönig-Verschnitt
dachte Macron natürlich: "La Union, c'est
moi!"
Natürlich ist er damit voll gegen die Wand
gefahren.
Macron hat wirlich niemanden überzeugt.
Während Paris zur europäischen Einheit aufrief,
blickten Warschau, Tallinn, Riga, Vilnius,
Prag, Stockholm, Helsinki, Kopenhagen, Bratislava...
Praktisch alle europäischen Hauptstädte...
nach Washington.
Für sie war klar: die NATO war der bestmögliche
Schutz, der einzig mögliche Schutz.
Und zu allem Überfluss für Macron kam dann
auch noch die Invasion selbst und es wurden
immer klarer, dass eine militärische Antwort
die einzig realistische und machbare war.
Die NATO gewann mit einem Erdrutschsieg gegen
Macron.
Sein Plan flog zum Fenster hinaus.
Und jetzt ratet mal, was er dann tat?
Blitzschnell vollzog er eine seiner klassichen
180-Grad-Wenden.
Eine Kursumkehr, die in gewisser Weise auch
während seines Wahlkampfs für die zweiten
Runde eine führende Rolle gespielt hat, als
er einige linke Positionen übernommen hat:
wie die Verlangsamung der Erhöhung des Rentenalters
oder die Hinwendung zu den Grünen.
Dabei handelt es sich um das genaue Gegenteil
dessen, was seine eigenen Wirtschaftsagenda
aussagt.
(Macron verwässert wichtige Rentenreform,
um die Linke zu umwerben.
FT)
Über das abstruse französische Rentensystem
haben wir sogar ein eigenes Video gemacht,
das ich Euch verlinken werde.
Aber offensichtlich ist Frankreich eben Frankreich
und wir würden es nicht für seine eigene
Natur verantwortlich machen, wenn es denn
seine eigene Rechnungen auch selbst bezahlen
würde.
Das Problem ist, dass all diese Fragen auch
die großen Unzulänglichkeiten des französischen
Präsidenten widerspiegeln: Macron hat dazu
beigetragen, Frankreich zu verbessern, aber
er hat nicht den radikalen Wandel herbeigeführt,
den er versprochen hatte.
Und er scheint auch nicht dazu bereit zu sein,
dies zu tun.
Macrons Sieg bedeutet Kontinuität in der
Wirtschaftspolitik und auch in der Außenpolitik.
Aber an dieser Stelle muss ich alle jene,
die dachten, noch traurigen könne es nicht
mehr kommen, eines besseren belehren: Obwohl
Macrons bisherigen Ergebnisse eher dürftig
waren, scheint es klar zu, dass er bei weitem
die beste Option war.
Und ich spreche nicht nur von Marine Le Pen.
Die Wahrheit ist, dass wir feststellen müssen,
dass die gesamte französische Politik total
ins Abseits abgedriftet ist und selbst Louis
De Funes Gendarmentruppe gegen die traurige
pariser Garde wie eine Eliteeinheit wirkt.
Setzt Euch jetzt lieber gut hin!
(POLITIK DER EXTREME)
Achtet bitte mal auf das folgende Statement:
(Sobald der russisch-ukrainische Krieg beendet
und durch einen Friedensvertrag geregelt ist,
werde ich mich für die Umsetzung einer strategischen
Annäherung zwischen der NATO und Russland
einsetzen.
Das liegt im Interesse Frankreichs und Europas
sowie der Vereinigten Staaten", Marine Le
Pen)
Eine Aussage, die besser zu verstehen ist,
wenn wir diese andere Verheißung in Betracht
ziehen:
(Le Pen verspricht, Frankreich aus dem NATO-Bündniskommando
zurückzuziehen, wenn sie die Präsidentschaftswahlen
gewinnt.
- Europa Press)
Le Pen sieht in ihrem bizarren Paralleluniversum
Frankreich nach wie vor als eine globale Supermacht.
Eine Supermacht, die einfach nur ihren Platz
in der Welt wieder zurückerobern muss.
Und um das zu erreichen, hat sie heinen besseren
Plan, als sich gegen die NATO und die Europäische
Union aufzulehnen, um eine protektionistische
Politik voranzutreiben, sich Moskau anzunähern
und sich das Land auch auf ein wirtschaftliches
und finanzpolitisches Himmelfahrtskommande
zu schicken.
Denn Le Pen hat nicht nur große Steuersenkungen
versprochen, sondern gleichzeitig auch gigantische
Ausgabensteigerungen.
Und was soll ich sagen?
Das ist normalerweise keine gute Kombination.
Es riecht eher nach wirklich plattem Populismus
als nach irgend etwas anderem, vor allem nicht
nach "gewusst wie".
Beispiel gefällig?
Le Pen sagt, sie wolle die Inflation bekämpfen,
indem sie den internationalen Handel bestraft
und die Mehrwertsteuer senkt, was die Nachfrage
der Haushalte noch mehr ankurbeln würde...
und damit auch die Preise...
Ähem.... wie bitte?
Um Euch eine Vorstellung davon zu geben: Wenn
Le Pens Versprechen würden ein zusätzliches
Defizit von 100 Milliarden Euro verursachen,
so dass das französische Haushaltsloch auf
über 250 Milliarden Euro pro Jahr explodieren
würde.
Und Ihr wisst, das ein französisches Haushaltsloch
spätestens seit Merkels Einknicken beim Thema
Eurobonds alles andere als ein rein französisches
Problem ist.
Was für eine schlaue Frau diese Le Pen doch
ist: Frankreich wieder zur Supermacht machen
und den deutschen Steuerzahler dafür blechen
lassen.
Unter ihren Vorschlägen finden sich auch
Dinge wie die Wiedereinführung der Vermögenssteuer,
die Verstaatlichung des Autobahnnetzes, die
Senkung des Rentenalters auf 60 Jahre und
die vergünstigte Kredite von bis zu 100.000
Euro an Familien, die mindestens drei Kinder
haben.
Nun ja, Europa braucht eine bessere Demographie,
das ist klar.
Aber die Frage ist, ob dieses Geld kinderreiche
Familien in Frankreich auch anspornen würde,
ihre Kinder zu bilden, zu emanzipieren und
in die moderne, produktive Gemeinschaft zu
integrieren.
In dieser Hinsicht hat sogar Macron die besseren
Konzepte vorzuweisen.
Denn in Frankreich kommen pro Frau heute schon
mehr Kinder zur Welt als im Rest Europas,
bei ihren Eltern handelt es sich jedoch meist
um bildungsferne Moslems mit sehr rückständige
Ansichten, was die Zukunft und Lebensweise
ihrer Kinder angeht.
Konflikte sind da vorprogrammiert und auch
ein Geldregen für diese Familien wird diese
nicht nachhaltig lösen können.
Ihr seht also: man braucht keinen Nazi-Holzhammer,
um Le Pen zu entzaubern, überhaupt macht
es keinen Sinn, hier irgendwie Rechts gegen
Links auszuspielen oder sich auch nur an diesen
Konzepten zur Einordnung der Politik Le Pens
wie auch Macrons zu orieren.
Im 18. Jahrhundert gab Frankreich der Welt
die Konzepte von Links und Rechts und heute
führt es einen neuen Übergang der politischen
Lager an, den der Analyst Gideon Rachman als
"Nationalisten" gegen "Internationalisten"
beschreibt.
Zwischen denen, die die Globalisierung fürchten,
und denen, die sie als Chance begreifen.
Le Pen selbst sagt es:
(Es gibt nicht mehr links oder rechts.
Die wahre Spaltung besteht zwischen den Patrioten
und den Globalisten".
Marine Le Pen)
Auch wenn dies eine zu starke Vereinfachung
des politischen Spektrums ist: trotz des Wahlergebnisses
ist die extreme Rechte von Le Pen und Co.
stärker denn je.
In der Tat lag sie bei den Jugendlichen und
der Arbeiterklasse vorn.
Sie könnte also durchaus die „Zukunft“
Frankreichs sein.
Nationalismus, Europaskepsis und die Ablehnung
von Einwanderung gewinnen immer mehr Anhänger.
Aber bei der Linken sieht es nicht viel anders
aus.
Die Tatsache, dass der Anführer des linken
Blocks ein so radikaler Kandidat wie Mélenchon
ist, weckt nicht gerade Vertrauen.
Die französische Gesellschaft scheint nicht
nur zunehmend gespalten und polarisiert zu
sein, sondern immer weiter an die Ränder
abzudriten.
Und wenn sich die Lage in Frankreich weiter
verschlechtert, könnte das Ergebnis bald
ganz anders aussehen.
In der ersten Runde dieser Wahlen blieben
der historischen linke Mitte kaum 2% der Stimmen
und die rechte Mitte erreichte nicht einmal
magere 5%.
Das politische Spektrum war also fast vollständig
zwischen Macrons Mitte und den Extremen gespalten.
("Macrons größte Herausforderung wird es
sein, ein Gefühl des Zusammenhalts in einem
extrem zersplitterten Land zu schaffen."
Tara Varma, European Council on Foreign Relations)
Aber zumindest für den Augenblick gibt es
fünf weitere Jahre der Kontinuität.
Eine „Kontinuität“ des Opportunismus,
der Wankelmut und der 180-Grad-Wenden.
Ein sich Durchwursteln, egal mit welch dreckigen
Mitteln.
Und die Alternative sähe noch viel dreckiger
aus.
Genau aus diesem Grund wurde die Wiederwahl
des französischen Präsidenten von fast allen
internationalen Führungspersönlichkeiten
mit lautem Jubel begrüßt, von Biden über
Scholz und Zelensky selbst bis hin zur Präsidentin
der Europäischen Kommission, Ursula Von der
Leyen.
(Glückwunsch an @EmmanuelMacron zu seiner
Wiederwahl.
Frankreich ist unser ältester Verbündeter
und ein wichtiger Partner bei der Bewältigung
globaler Herausforderungen.
Ich freue mich auf unsere weitere enge Zusammenarbeit
- auch bei der Unterstützung der Ukraine,
der Verteidigung der Demokratie und der Bekämpfung
des Klimawandels.)
Jetzt braut sich eine neue Schlacht zusammen,
die so genannte dritte Runde: Macrons Partei
muss die Wahlen zur Nationalversammlung im
Juni gewinnen, damit der Präsident nach eigenem
Gutdünken regieren kann.
Und, was soll ich sagen…
auch wenn ich jetzt resigniert klinge... angesichts
dessen, was wir gesehen haben, wollen wir
hoffen, dass er Erfolg hat!
Macron erweist sich zwar nicht als revolutionärer
Präsident, aber zumindest hat er es geschafft,
das verrostete Ruder der französischen Politik
mehr als seine Vorgänger herumzureißen.
Er ist das geringste Übel.
Trotzdem: es wird nicht genug sein.
Und unter den Alternativen scheint es nur
alte Formeln zu geben, von echter Innovation
und zukunftsweisenden Veränderungen keine
Spur.
Veränderungen, von denen Frankreich viele
bräuchte, sehr viele: in der Wirtschaft,
bei der Sozial- und Rentenpolitik, der Sicherheits-
und Außenpolitik usw.
Überraschend war auf jeden Fall das Ergebniss
der Wahl in den französischen Überseegebieten:
Es unterschiedet sich diametral von dem in
der Hauptstadt.
Denn je weiter ein Ort von Paris entfernt
liegt, desto besser schnitt Marine Le Pen
ab.
Das galt sowohl für’s Mutterland, aber
vor allem für Orte wie Reunion, Guadeloupe,
Französisch-Guayana und Martinique.
Diese hat sie bereits gewonnen, einige sogar
mit großem Vorsprung.
Was also geht in Frankreichs Übersee-Departements
genau vor sich?
Warum ticken die Uhren dort nochmal ganz anders
als auf dem europäischen Kontinent?
Das, liebe VisualPolitik-Fans, werden wir
Euch in einem der nächsten Videos hier auf
unserem Kanal zeigen.
Vergesst also bitte nicht, den Kanal zu abonnieren
und ganz wichtig: auch das Glöckchen für
die Benachrichtigungen zu aktivieren.
Der Abo-Status wird vom YouTube-Algorithmus
mittlerweile weitgehend ignoriert.
Das was früher das Abo war, ist heute also
das Glöckchen.
Kontrolliert also bitte nochmal das Glöckchen,
auch wenn Ihr schon ein Abo habt, nur dann
verpasst Ihr keine Folge.
So, und nun dürft Ihr Euch in den Kommentaren
über Frankreich und Macron auslassen:
Was denkt Ihr über die Ergebnisse der französischen
Wahlen?
Was erwartet Ihr von seiner zweiten Amtszeit?
Glaubt Ihr, dass Frankreich es schaffen wird,
einen Erfolgskurs einzuschlagen?
Und vor allem: was würde wohl Sigmund Freund
über Emmanuel Macron und Marine Le Pen sagen?
Ich hoffe, dass Euch dieses Video, gefallen
hat.
Falls ja, gebt uns bitte ein Like und teilt
es mit Euren Freunden.
Natürlich freuen wir uns auch jederzeit über
eine Spende von Euch, mit der Ihr uns helft,
dieses Projekt weiterzuführen.
Den PayPal-Link dazu findet Ihr in der Beschreibung
unter dem Video.
Macht’s gut und bis bald!